there are tens of thousands of games to
play on pc with more being added every
single day so it's a real challenge to
come up with a best of all time list
instead we rounded up the top 20 pc
games to play in 2022
some were released this year others are
ones that have stood the test of time
but regardless there should be something
here for every type of pc gamer
there are many asymmetrical horror
survival games take evil dead and even
predator for example but the best is
still dead by daylight which puts you in
the shoes of either a classic horror
movie killer or a hapless survivor since
its release in 2016 the game's roster
has exploded featuring characters from
stranger things hellraiser and even
other games like resident evil if
getting spooked with your buds sounds
good to you then dead by daylight is a
great choice
it's true that since its release in 2011
the elder scrolls 5 skyrim has been
ported to just about every platform that
can play games including amazon alexa
speakers and smart refrigerators i
didn't catch that
first
but the king of all skyrim versions is
the one on pc and it's not even close
that's because the pc version gives you
access to years of mods created by the
skyrim community from adding serious rpg
story content to providing ridiculous
possibilities like replacing all dragons
with thomas the tank engine the pc
version of skyrim adds nearly endless
options to an already expansive enormous
game
you can never go wrong with a one-two
combo of rpg goodness and tactical
action something which wild myth excels
at an examination of the power of
stories wilder myth delivers on an
ambitious idea with flexible systems and
imaginative campaigns what starts out as
stock standard rpg fare quickly evolves
along the way into something that feels
grander and more personal while
challenging gameplay and procedurally
generated content adds a few extra
hurdles along the way
despite releasing five years ago destiny
2 remains one of the most popular live
service multiplayer games around while
the sequel started off on a strong note
it has only gotten better thanks to
consistent updates and expansions that
delivered a steady stream of enthralling
first-person shooter content and it's
not even close to being too late to jump
into destiny 2 as more content is coming
through 2023 destiny 2's plethora of
content would be nothing without strong
mechanics and overarching systems that
keep you grinding away for new gear
bungie crafted one of the best-feeling
first-person shooters we've played in
recent years so it offers a constant
source of fun regardless of whether
you're making your way through story
missions going on challenging raids with
friends or battling in the crucible it's
a wonderful game that digs its teeth
into you the more you play and it's
easily one of the best cooperative pc
games available
this is the best three dollars you'll
ever spend and you can quote me on that
either use wized or the arrow keys to
move around as your character
automatically attacks the beasties that
swarm you level up to unlock even more
abilities to help fend them off survive
long enough and you'll end up facing
death himself it's easy to pick up and
tricky to master and one of the games i
can't stop obsessing over
one of the most original games of recent
memory before your eyes has a simple
premise that hinges on your eyes
controlling the entire experience
through a webcam you play as a recently
deceased person and the game chronicles
your life but the catch is every time
you blink time moves forward it's a
terrific idea incredibly well
implemented and ties in perfectly with
themes of memories life and storing
those precious moments within ourselves
it's unusual but packs a heavyweight
emotional punch you won't want to take
your eyes off this game for a single
instant
disco elysium is perhaps unrivaled when
it comes to games writing it places you
in the role of a detective suffering
from amnesia and a serious hangover his
quest to unravel a baffling murder and
the details of his life that he's
forgotten takes you on an absolutely
stunning adventure that thrives on its
choice-based gameplay and exquisite
dialogue disco elysium balances humor
and serious life dilemmas with
astounding grace and the freedom it
gives you to shape the narrative and
your interactions with its many colorful
characters you meet allows you to make
this detective story your own the final
cut comes with a few extra missions and
a full voice cast there's seriously
nothing else like it
the final fantasy series is known for
having a strong focus on storytelling
with colorful characters who get into
over-the-top battles and the mmo final
fantasy 14 manages to stay true to what
the series is all about 14 is the
franchise's second crack at an mmo and
it features a sprawling story about
rebellion equality and friendship that
manages to hit the same highs of the
franchise's best single-player games
final fantasy xiv offers an excellent
gateway for lapsed and new mmo players
to jump into with its expanded free
trial which you can play through the
entirety of roral reborn and the
award-winning heavensward expansion up
to level 60 for playing with
restrictions on playtime i'm sorry i had
to do it
at first glance inscription looks like a
mixture of tabletop card games with a
healthy dose of deck building thrown in
for good measure as you risk your very
life in a high stakes game of survival
throw in some roguelite progression
mystery and a very creepy art direction
and you've got the perfect mix for a
game that hides more mesmerizing content
beneath its surface absolutely strange
while it deals out its ideas that
weirdness makes inscription the type of
game that'll live rent free in your head
long after you've played your last card
one of the most original indie games of
last year loop hero can't be defined by
any single genre a creatively clever mix
of rpg staples deck building charm and
brutal strategy loop hero merges all of
these elements together to create a bold
and fresh adventure that'll keep you
occupied for hours on end
in v rising you awaken as a weakened
vampire in a world overrun by humans and
it's up to you to regain your strength
gather resources build your kingdom and
become top dog once again since its
release in may 2022 it's already sold
1.5 million copies and it's still in
early access you can either play alone
or with friends but regardless you're in
for a bloody good time
only the stanley parable a nearly
unexplainable game where things get
regularly weird and meta could get away
with hiding what amounts to a sequel
within the frame of an expanded
re-release of the original game like the
original title the strange and
hilariously distracted nature of the
stanley parable is something that you
have to experience for yourself as words
simply do not do it justice with the
ultra deluxe edition you're getting an
experience that feels like a game within
a game adding the illusion of freedom
and other surprises along the way it's
nothing short of a clever and
thought-provoking examination of video
games and the relationship that we have
with them
the initial response to valrant was that
it's basically a mash-up where overwatch
meets counter-strike and yeah that's
pretty accurate but that's also a good
thing because valorent draws on many of
the strengths of those games to make
something unique valorance has seen
content updates and changes since its
launch and it's been quite successful so
you can expect the game to get more
support moving forward if a competitive
first-person shooter with layered
tactics precise gun play and intense
moments is your thing valorent is worth
a try
if you're hungry for a zelda-like
adventure then tunic is well equipped to
fill you up with some nostalgic and
cathartic gameplay not just an homage to
zelda games of the nes and snares eras
tunic's familiar green clothing and
swordplay in a vibrant and colorful
world is balanced by a collection of
amazing puzzles and challenges that
require quick reflexes and superb wits
evocative of a bygone time and somehow
still feeling like a completely fresh
take on the subject matter this love
letter to the past was years in the
making and more than delivers on its
elevator pitch of exploration and wonder
have you ever thought to yourself i'd
like to try my hand at speed running
well neon white might just be your way
in as an assassin given a chance of
redemption by killing demons in heaven
you quickly make your way through levels
collecting soul cards which you can
either use as weapons or burn to give
you movement abilities to complete
levels even quicker there are
leaderboards so no doubt you'll be
pressing f and then spacebar to refresh
your game to beat your friend's scores
every few minutes
few games get the absolute thrill of
driving a ridiculously fast car the way
that the forza horizon series does and
its latest chapter is another example of
pure petrolhead bliss shifting to the
warm climate of mexico forza horizon 5
sticks to its template and hits top gear
right from the start with its selection
of vehicles activities and a constant
sense of reward for being a speed demon
beyond its superb gameplay forza horizon
5 also takes time to emphasize a
personal connection between man and
machine as it balances epic showcase
events with personal moments of
reflection and car culture and did i
mention that a hot wheels expansion was
just around the corner
even if it took a few years the wait for
one of the best playstation games on the
market to hit pc was well worth it while
previous god of war games emphasized
gratuitous violence and a character with
the personality of a very angry
cardboard box sony's reinvention of
kratos helped create a more nuanced and
layered hero that doesn't mean that
there wasn't a satisfying amount of
carnage to engage in though as developer
sony santa monica expanded on kratos's
brutal abilities in methodical ways and
gave him plenty of new tools to play
with in a nordic sandbox
a strong contender for the very best
game of 2022 from software's latest dip
into dark fantasy and brutal combat is
the studio at its very best the lands
between are a massive sandbox in which
to explore as a newly risen tarnished
warrior and every corner of this world
hides a secret that'll take you down a
path of danger in exchange for
fascinating lore and powerful rewards
while eldon ring doesn't stray too far
from the usual from software formula it
does polish the elegant gameplay and
signature style of that studio to a
mirror finish that's beautiful to behold
and loaded with dozens of hours of
content to dive into
after monster hunter world set a new
benchmark for what the capcom series was
capable of monster hunter ryze had some
big dragon leather boots to fill rise is
a showcase of what happens when you take
the lessons learned from something new
and apply it to an older example of
monster hunter greatness as the newest
game in the series expertly shifted back
to all out action originally designed
for the nintendo switch ryze's port to
pc came with a ton of free post launch
content graphical upgrades and
performance enhancements that make this
version the definitive edition of an
already fantastic game
it all starts with an old broken down
farm and a handful of seeds you clear
out the weeds and rocks until you get
tired and then you do it all again you
get into the rhythm of daily life
visiting friends watering crops
occasional light spelunking before you
know it it's been 75 hours and you're
mostly managing your complex irrigation
system and planning for next season's
harvest stardew valley is a friendly
relaxing experience that also somehow
manages to be endlessly addictive and
while it's appeared on just about every
platform pc often gets the first chance
to test all of the little quality of
life tweaks and new features that come
with patches plus there is a huge
library of mods that let you tweak
various gameplay elements give the game
a new aesthetic and even add extensive
new content and characters
so there we have it 20 of the best games
to play on pc right now if i missed any
let me know in the comments below and
maybe i'll do a follow-up video you can
find me on twitter at lucy james games
and playing neon white where i'm
desperately trying to beat everyone's
scores for all the latest on pc gaming
make sure to follow gamespot
you